how's it going everybody it's Warren
happy New Year's Eve to everybody and
Happy New Year's Day in case this video
gets out kind of late and it's already
New Year's for some of you but good news
we are starting the New Year's off the
right way with spider-man 3 News
Spidey gave us quite the scare this year
spider-man far from home was the first
spider-man film to gross over a billion
dollars and for a little bit there it
was looking like we weren't going to
have Tom Hollands spider-man in the MCU
going off of the massive success that
spider-man far from home had Marvel
wanted a little bit more ownership with
spider-man and Sony thought they could
do it by themself given the recent
success but luckily for us spider-man
remains in the MCU and Sony and Disney
worked out a deal primarily because of a
drunken phone call from Tom Holland to
the CEO of Disney and Marvel Studios and
again today we have news that Tom
Holland is coming in clutched for the
next spider-man film quick reminder only
about 13 hours left depending on when I
get this video out to enter for the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do is subscribe when notifications
turned on and click the link in the
description down below so today we have
a new report from deadline about
spider-man 3 according to Deadline
spider-man 3 is going to start filming
very soon
actually this upcoming summer so the
summer of 2020 is when it's going to
start filming which means we should get
an official title for the movie not too
long from now according to Deadline Tom
Holland will be filming the summer which
pushes his movie Uncharted by sony back
this isn't the first time that the movie
has been pushed back as it's lost a few
directors along the way but it's nice to
know that Tom Holland prioritizes
spider-man he's definitely fought to
keep spider-man in the MCU and now he's
prioritizing this movie over his other
ones we've also learned that spider-man
3 is going to take place no longer than
6 months after the events of spider-man
far from home now of course this makes
perfect sense because the last time that
we saw Peter Parker his identity was
revealed the whole world knows that he
is spider-man now but the whole world
also thinks that he killed Mysterio and
was going to kill a bunch of people so
of course spider-man 3 is going to deal
with the repercussions of that now the
schedule that spider-man 3 has is kind
of the same as far from home film in the
summer to release a year later because
right now Tom Hollands spider-man 3 has
a release date of July SiC
teenth of 2021 so that means development
of the film is definitely well underway
which of course means that we should be
finding out a lot more information about
the movie very soon now executive
producer Amy Pascal and owner of Pascal
Pictures did say not too long ago might
I add that Spider Man homecoming and
Spider Man far from home have introduced
all of the characters necessary for the
sinister six so there is a possibility
that Spider Man 3 could introduce the
sinister six
but the real hype right now is the fact
that Marvel Studios could put Deadpool
in spider-man 3
we know that Deadpool 3 is already in
development and there's a lot of
evidence that suggests that Deadpool 3
actually has been in development for a
pretty long time now and if that is the
case they could have definitely talked
about Deadpool appearing in spider-man 3
to help him out with this current
situation some people are thinking that
venom could appear but right now as it
stands sony is talking about Tom
Hollands spider-man appearing in venom 2
so we most likely aren't getting venom
in spider-man 3
so Deadpool is a legitimate possibility
although nothing has been confirmed yet
and there's also been a previous leak
that says Kraven the hunter is going to
be introduced in this film because he is
working for Mysterio and Mysterio is
still alive now I'm actually one of the
people who thinks that Mysterio is still
alive he's such an amazing villain and
Jake Gyllenhaal did such an amazing job
with him I don't think they'd kill him
off that easily plus he's the master of
illusions this is what Mysterio does he
makes you think he's dead only to come
back and seek his revenge so I don't
think we've seen the last of Mysterio
but I would definitely love to see
Deadpool
enter spider-man 3 to help him out with
either the sinister six or Kraven the
hunter and Mysterio but let me know what
you all think who would you like to see
team-up with spider-man and spider-man 3
be sure to let me know below give this
video like and don't forget to subscribe
with notifications turned on so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 and remember about only
13 hours left to enter the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof